I
wanted to write about what it means that
some people see me,
they have to earn or have to do
something to deserve access to.
Things that we think about is basic
necessity.
So how hard can you work to earn access
to a meal every night or like earn or
what do you have to do to deserve a good
education?
What do you have to do to deserve to
have housing and that's one of the ways
that race sort of works in this country
is that there's some people that are
deemed inherently worthy.
So we think about the way whiteness and
white supremacy people are just deemed
white people are just deemed worthy of
things,
but there's this notion that you need to
work extra hard to deserve a great
public education.
I am from Baltimore and we think about
the school system in Baltimore City is
not funded equitably at all and it's
like,
well,
what do those kids have to do to like
earn equitable funding?
They actually don't need to do anything
besides just be alive and one of the
things that we need to do is make sure
that we set up a system where people
just have the basic necessities like
food,
water,
education.
We can guarantee that there's no reason
why we don't have it here.
So I actually think about the diversity
and equality and equity,
right?
The equality is everybody gets the same
thing.
Equity is that people get what they need
and deserve.
And then the worker justice,
we are almost always fighting for
equity.
So we think about things like school
funding.
We are not asking for equal funding.
We know that it just costs more to
educate kids who grew up in poverty.
It costs more to educate kids with
special needs and we know that we need
to pay that cost,
that those kids deserve.
That we're not saying that every kid,
uh,
it costs the same to educate every kid.
That's just not true.
We want a world of equity where people
get what they need and deserve.
We know the disparities around criminal
justice,
that there are disparities around race
and we want an equitable system that
doesn't penalize people for where they
live,
how they show up,
what zip code they come from.
So the difference between equity and
equality as an important distinction and
the only way to get to equality equality
and access,
how whatever metric of equality you want
is by having equity of resources,
right?
Equity of experiences.
I did the equity pieces that you need
something different and you deserve
something different.
And from a system level I'm going to
make sure that you have access to that.
So I was talking to somebody about about
who's named Swanson a and she was like,
people should have to work for food
stamps because if they work for it
though dignity and I'm like,
you know,
not eating.
I think it's pretty addictive.
Like not having food is a lack of
dignity right there,
right?
That like food is one of those basic
things.
We have enough food that we can beat
everybody.
We have enough water to everybody can,
you know,
have a,
a meal at three meals every single day.
Like we can guarantee those things.
We don't need to artificially create
this requirement that people like work
so they can earn food,
like we can actually guarantee these
basic things for people,
uh,
in one of the things that we have to do
as we fight for social justice,
as talk about these things as basic as
they are,
the,
it's not radical to believe that we can
live in a world with the police.
Don't kill people.
It's not radical to say that every kid
should be able to read and write.
It's not radical or extreme to say that
we can feed every single person every
single day.
That the only radical thing about it is
that we have to say in the first place
like,
that is actually where the radical part
comes in.
And we,
I think about that because polarization
thrives in a world of extremes.
And so often people want to paint our
positions is extreme.
It's an extreme position to say that
there should be equity advantage.
That's not extreme.
The extreme thing about it is that we
don't have it right now and that we have
defined for it.
I was in a meeting once and we were
talking about welfare and it was people
from the right and the left and one of
her sort of,
there was a person in it who was sort of
against welfare and her push was like,
you know,
people need to,
people need to like earn it.
People need to work hard for it and if
they work hard for it they'll feel
better and it's like A.
I don't know.
I think that people like have already
worked hard to like get a meal.
I think that people being alive,
it's like enough of that and there's
some people who feel like they just
deserve everything.
They're like.
One of the ways that white supremacy
works is that people really do feel like
they've already earned.
They put in the hard work,
they've done something or the,
all the,
all the things that they get are
actually the benefits of their hard
work.
You think about the way wealth works in
this country is that in 2023,
the median wealth for black people's
gonna be $0.
The lowest recorded.
It's since you've been recording about
them this way and you didn't go to the
median wealth of $0 and you think about
white wealth,
which is will be around $100,000 in the
medium.
Black walls will be zero.
Is that.
It sounds like why people like worked
hard for that.
It's not like white people,
like every white person was like some
entrepreneur that like did all these
wealth building things.
The government literally gave white
people.
Well,
the government gave white people housing
loans for very little with very little
interest in government gave white people
land.
The highway administration created the
suburbs and you think about what it
means that the government gave people a.
gave white people like education in
mass,
like those things contributed to white
wealth,
but there are.
People were like,
I worked really hard and say,
how hard did you work for a system that
just like benefits your skin colored
every turn of the way you didn't do
that,
you know?
How hard did you work for every band aid
to look like you?
How hard did you work for nude to be the
color of your skin and not mine?
Like you didn't do that.
A system did that and like that.
You benefit from the system and part of
the work of white people is to
understand the privilege of whiteness
and to understand how a system provided
that and work to dismantle it and
actually is dangerous a teacher.
So there's a study that came out that
was the first time measures,
how meritocracy impacts middle schoolers
and it's like a seventh grade in seventh
grade kids and it shows that kids
actually kids of color do worse later if
they believe that meritocracy is like a
real thing because the systems are to
bear down on them in hallways.
They think that it's a result of like
dumb,
just not working hard,
and it's like,
no,
we know that the way systemic racism
shows up later like means that no matter
how gifted you are,
how great you are,
the outcome still just aren't the same.
We know what the criminal justice here
you think about New York City,
that 90 percent of the people arrested
for marijuana are black and brown.
You and I both know that the 90 percent
of the people in New York City smoking
weed or not black or brown.
When we think about the arrests,
we think about disparities in education.
The meritocracy causes people to blame
themselves for outcomes and not
realizing that the system is almost
guaranteeing instead of outcomes.